يحصد وارواح الاف الامريكيين كل عام وامام
جبروته عجزه مختلف الادارات المتعاقده في
العام الماضي فقط راح ضحيته اكثر من 44
الف امريكي عدو امريكا الاول وصفه بايدن
بالوباء وهو هنا لا يتحدث عن فيروس كورونا
المقصود هو السلاح المنفلت الذي يفتكو
بالامريكيين كل عام ظاهره يزداد ضحاياها
كل عام
105 حوادث اطلاق النار خلال الايام
الاربعه وستين الاولى من العام الجاري
بزياده قدرت باربعين في المئه وللمناسبه
بالمقارنه ذهب ضحيه الارهاب في امريكا ما
يقارب ثلاثه الاف شخص ولمكافحته انفقت
واشنطن اكثر من ثلاثه تريليون دولار خلال
عقدين فان السلاح المنفلت بقي خارج
المكافحه لا قانون جاد للحد من تجارته
وبما ان الشارع يدفع الثمن فلا تهمه هويته
وحتى اذا كان قاصرا مكافحه الارهاب وتجاره
السلاح وجهان لعمله واحده كلاهما يدر
اموالا ضخمه على الشركات وبلغه الارقام
انتجت امريكا خلال العام الماضي واحدا
وسبعين مليون قطعه السلاح صدرت منها سبعه
ملايين ونصف المليون فقط الى الخارج
65 مليون قطعه منها بقيت في امريكا
والمستفيد 17 الف شركه مصنعه للاسلحه صدور
قرار ايضا يضر باعمالها مخاطره يخشاها اي
رئيس امريكي اما الشارع فيسمي هذه الشركات
يسعى رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى فرض
المزيد من الاجراءات الراميه للحد من
حوادث اطلاق النار المنتشره بكثره في
البلاد بايدن وقع على امر تنفيذي قال انه
يهدف الى الحد من عنف السلاح بما في ذلك
التغييرات التي يمكن ان تزيد من عدد مشتري
الاسلحه الذين يخضعون لفحص امني وبحسب نص
الامر التنفيذي فيجب على وزراء العدل
والصحه والتعليم ووزير الامن الداخلي
اتخاذ اجراءات لتنفيذ قانون المجتمعات
الاكثر امنا الذي وقعه بايدن العام الماضي
بالاضافه الى توسيع الحملات الفيدراليه
الحاليه لتعزيز التخزين الامن للاسلحه
الناريه وجدد بايدن دعوته للكونجرس لاتخاذ
اجراءات اضافيه حد من عنف الاسلحه بما في
ذلك عن طريق حظر الاسلحه الهجوميه
واستيراد تقديم سوابق عدليه للاشخاص في
جميع مبيعات الاسلحه